[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions that this is the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i am ramsey personality rachel
cruz here and co-hosting with me today
is dr john deloney welcome john thank
you so much glad to be on with you and
if you guys had and also with you
a question about life money
relationships anything and everything
give us a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're gonna start
off with jared in jacksonville hey jared
welcome to the show
thank you guys for having me i
appreciate it absolutely how can we help
hey so i'm a recent college graduate and
i've got a job lined up in the icu and
was curious if i should use the money
i've got saved up and start focusing on
buying a house
or
save that money and put it towards grad
school in a few years
is grad school
gonna be a reality for you do you know
or is that just a possibility
yeah so i think i'm pretty much
determined on going to crna school and
getting my anesthesia degree okay and i
have to work two years in the icu before
going back so
right now it's kind of just uh whether
or not
it's smart to rent um i know the housing
market has been insane now so i don't
know if it's smart and wanted to get
your opinion on on getting a house
yeah it's a great question
you know i mean whenever there's a big
life change that's happening you're
graduating you're getting married
anything when it comes to home buying i
always kind of just like to take a deep
breath because there can be a lot of
change that occurs whether it's moving
cities
um or what you're wanting before this
life change could be different than what
you want after and all of that so
especially since you know you're going
to be going to school you might be not
going to school in jacksonville right
like you could be moving
to be going to school so
if you're not going to be settled for
more than four or five years i would not
recommend buying a home because taking
it and because the market it is so crazy
i would hate for you to like buy at the
top for instance and you know and then
who knows 24 months what it looks like
so
if i were you i would definitely rant
because this is a big transitional
period and i think there's something
about permission maybe i'm reading into
this call but you have permission to
rent dude and the people you work with
are going to be like you're just pissing
your money away dude
and you can just smile at them because
you'll know you're unshackled and you
can move where you want to you can
date who you want to when you want you
know i mean you'll be free to move about
the country while you're
sure getting your two years in going to
grad school and stuff
okay perfect and i know i'm gonna try to
save about thirty thousand dollars a
year you know to help go towards
your down payment and masters so i'm
definitely trying to live frugally and
even though i'm renting save as much as
i can that's awesome i appreciate you
guys yeah you bet get some roommates man
you'll have a couple of fun years and
you're not gonna you're not gonna hang
out anyway you're gonna be working like
crazy and it's so funny it's like the
home ownership conversation like there
is something very special about owning
your home right like there's you're
putting roots down it's there but you
also don't know and don't think about
always
all the other expenses that come along
with being a homeowner like it's up to
you like there's no there's no there's
no one anyone so
for a couple years uh for one year was
one year maybe 18 months when sheila and
i sold her house and moved into
residence hall to pay off everything
i had done the math on how much
our mortgage was how much we would save
yeah
we saved infinitely more and i had not
calculated the hoses and the repairs and
the the nozzle on the thing and the way
and all
none of that stuff and then you add up
the electricity and the it's all yours
the air conditioner yeah i undershot it
probably by half if not three times i
couldn't um believe how much money we
saved by um
renting by by not owning or yes yes i
know winston's grandfather he's passed
now but he always said he said the
cheapest day you buy the cheapest day
you own a home is the day you buy it or
so it was something
yeah
because then from there the costs it
goes up so
such a good question all right up next
we have alex here from washington kent
washington hey alex welcome to the show
hey rachel hey john happy monday happy
monday how can we help
so i have a personal loan for my
mortgage at zero percent um i am trying
to figure out if it is smarter to
set aside
my um those extra payments i want to do
um to clarify i'm instead free so i'm
just building up my emergency fund
um
and
because i don't have any interest on it
if i should just set aside that money
maybe find something to put it in just
to gain a little interest or if i should
just keep tackling
on it
since there's no interest on it sure so
you took out the personal loan as your
mortgage is what you're saying
correct and how much is it
um it's around 300. around 300. so you
have like a family member that loans you
300k for your house
indeed okay all right
yeah so i mean in that case i think i
still because it is for your home and
because of the amount and what it is i
would still i would bucket that uh with
the baby steps in baby step six so i
would go ahead and go through
and go ahead and you know continue baby
step three saving up your emergency
funds start funding retirement and then
you i'm sorry baby step six and then i
would tackle it as if it's baby step six
for you uh where you're paying this off
so so the the zero interest thing
again people get so tied up in the math
and like okay i can put my money here
and earn this and that and that but for
right now i would i would follow the
baby steps alex and then when you get to
that baby step six that 300 000 yeah
that's your mortgage is how i would look
at it and that you're you're putting
that money in and especially since it's
from a family member yeah
that gives you who is your family member
alex who is it
oh it's my
father
i so i i'm not gonna ask you to talk say
anything negative about your old man but
does it feel weird having this hanging
over you
because it would for me and i love my
dad no it doesn't for you
no i have a really good relationship
with him okay um what we've seen over
and over is
the relationship's great and dad is so
well-meaning and the recipient is so
well-meaning
and then
um let's don't drive that car or no my
grandkids going to go to this school or
mike why are they wearing this clothes
you don't even have a house payment and
it begins to cloud things a little bit
you may be the one in a million who dad
just wrote an interest-free 300 000 chat
because he loves the sun and if that's
if that's the case then way to go i'd
still pay it off as quick as i could
yeah um and baby step six but in most
cases when you once when a family member
or someone you love someone uh someone
you are in relationship with
you owe them money it just changes
everything it changes the dynamics in
little ways in big ways and i steer
clear of it and it and again i love that
you pointed out cause i'm like it could
be well-meaning oh almost always as well
yeah but there it it there's always this
thing because the borrower's slave to
the lender when your master
is your dad it does there's a level
there that it's like okay you oh there's
a little bit of that string attached in
life that you owe this to me and there's
also this when your spouse is to think
through like to think
my father-in-law
owns us you know what i mean like our
father-in-law is i would rather pay the
interest rate
and get a traditional mortgage
then take a zero percent interest from a
from friend or family member that money
would be worth preservation of that
relationship of that the safety net
yeah of keeping it away yeah it's an
interesting thing and again money is a
tool right to help you in your life and
a lot of parents and family members they
do this to help
but just be careful alex and again pay
it off asap on the baby step six thanks
for calling this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i am
rachel cruz co-hosting today with dr
john delony so give us a call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're here hanging out with you america
talking about your life your money
relationships anything and everything so
give us a call uh we have kyle from
atlanta up next hey kyle welcome to the
ramsay show hey guys it's really cool to
talk to you guys really appreciate it
absolutely we're glad you called how can
we help
um just a couple of quick questions and
then a bonus question if you guys have
to uh well i think we got some time kyle
so yeah i've recently just got engaged
and congrats
thank you
and i'm wondering if
me and her should
stop our
retirement investments to help cash flow
the wedding and honeymoon and we also
just bought a house
and that sort of thing and the other
thing too is since we are engaged do we
need to start combining our money now or
wait till after the wedding
dude that's a great question man so
great questions when it comes to are
y'all debt-free
yes sir um
she's currently living with her mom like
i said we just bought a house so aside
from my mortgage yeah i i would i would
pause and just pack up pile up cash here
the the end goal here is to not um
to get through your wedding without
owning anybody any money don't go back
in debt the one thing i would say is i
rachel stop me if i'm wrong here oh well
i i'm okay
with you pausing it
i wouldn't and here's why it would put a
cap on me because with all this extra
i'm gonna spin what's there
and i'm going to buzz through whatever
money is there and get right to the edge
and so there's some ways that um
continuing to invest in your retirement
keeping your investments going is going
to act as a governor on your expenses
yeah how much do you guys make a year
kyle how much do you make and how much
does she make
together we make roughly 120. oh yeah
you can cash flow this i would um i i
probably wouldn't i mean yeah that i
mean with the boundary in place that
you're not going to go into debt for
anything and to say okay let's just say
yeah that we um yeah throw as much as we
can and and when are you when is the
wedding if it's april now when is it
like it won't be
next year um
oh dude you got plenty of money kyle
save up your money
just keep running yeah you have your
money yeah and you guys it's just the
only thing is since we just bought the
house we're trying to keep everything as
separate as possible so she's moving
into the house here in june when it gets
finished being built
and i won't move in until may so we're
gonna be paying like two separate rents
and or you know her the mortgage and my
rats
kind of
uh that's how
my attention starts to come in because
our horror savings is kind of over with
yeah why are you guys waiting a year
yeah dude go to the jp man
come up here somebody here in the office
will marry you
are you ordained yeah what if john
marries you kyle come up here i'll do it
no no we're joking but for real for real
what's what's what's causing y'all to
wait you're owning a house i mean you're
doing it you're
yeah we kind of do not involve
housemates because we wasn't sure if
we'd be able to what we could afford in
six months yeah just with interest rates
and everything so
um of jumped on there early
and i feel like it's the right decision
the best decision for us so just jump on
your mirror look you can get married and
then have a big party in a year from now
and you can cashflow the whole thing
um
dude i've i married somebody i
officiated a wedding in my living room
uh somebody stopped by the house and was
like hey we have this plan and then all
of a sudden this got cancelled on this
and we're in a mess now we've already
got this and so dude you can go find it
that's a whole other call i know you
didn't call about that but i wouldn't
here's what i wouldn't do i you're going
to drive each other bonkers because
you're half playing married and you're
half not
and you're going to drive each other
bananas and you're going to blow a bunch
of money just go i mean expedite
everything you all made a big grown up
decision to pull the trigger on the
house then just go ahead and call it and
get married and move on the other thing
about joining your bank accounts i would
not do that until you're married um as
much as you love her and y'all bought a
house to go and all that i would not
join bank accounts until y'all are fully
legally married and it makes me nervous
call that y'all bought a house so i'm
hoping it's under one of your names not
not both it's this whole situation makes
me just a little bit y'all are getting a
little ahead of you ahead of yourself so
listen
yeah it's done in june you said move you
know have her move in and june was done
you guys get married in july august
that's four or five months
move in call it a day and you're running
you're running life going about your
life and and the in the wedding it's
always an interesting conversation
because weddings
they they are so blown up in our heads
right of what i don't know if it's just
america no because other cultures
yeah they take you know three weeks
three weeks celebrating some places but
but listen and it's an exciting time in
all of it but we get so caught up in
that day
and my my brother he's been married now
a few years but i remember i told him i
was like take your wedding budget split
it in half
and save the rest for marriage therapy
after because
like like you're it really is one day
and how much effort and time we think
about like that like your marriage is a
lifetime so we're not trying to rush you
into a marriage call but obviously
you're engaged and obviously she's the
one the way you were talking so um i i
would just not put as much stock in the
wedding itself and be like okay let's
let's start yeah go get married and then
if you want to have a party a year from
now kovitch i i feel like kova took all
the rules off yes like like people
getting married over zoom or
just like it is what it is we i love you
you love me we're gonna start our lives
together let's just go make it happen
and then we can rally around a party
later
absolutely i mean
yep and the party could be at the next
person's house here michael from florida
michael welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are y'all doing doing good
i see i see the word pool coming up so i
thought well that'd be a great place for
uh old kyle to have
a lot of weddings
how can we help michael
i'm trying to get some advice as to
whether or not my wife and i are making
a financial mistake by putting an
in-ground pool on our property okay
so we have the money to cash flow it we
have no debt other than our home
we bought our house right before covet
popped off pretty strong two years ago
the house we were living at flyer had a
pool
and it's something that we both want and
enjoyed having um i just don't know if
i'm terrified about spending the money
she's not she's all over it
michael put in a pool
michael don't put in a pool i'm just
kidding
hey how much how much do you own your
house
so currently uh the mortgage is about
182 but with the way property values and
everything has gone in our area we're
sitting
on a
piece of property worth offers of 350 at
the moment but so you owe 180 left on
your mortgage
that's correct
oh this 60 would bring you down to 120
and then a couple more hard months and
you're at five digits man
that is exactly what i tried to tell my
wife that she sit back sat back a little
bit
i know that we could have that house
paid off in less than five years
that was my goal do you all have kids
yes what are their ages
two daughters one is six and it'd be
eighteen the other one's taken to be
eleven
eighteen and eleven though you just said
yes that's correct oh so this pool is
for y'all it's not even for them
well yeah
for the 11 year yeah the 11 year old to
use it the 18 year old may not so much
here so i i don't think there's there's
no there's not a right or wrong here
here's the deal here's the one it might
be split on it
rachel's all about pools she loves a
pool and i've never had one so i just go
to other people's pools i've never had a
pool either i've never had a house with
a pool no you haven't no oh okay
my parents moved into a house at the
pool when i left for college so it
doesn't count that's a good move i don't
count yeah but um
yeah because here's the deal michael you
guys you're out of debt you're funding
your retirement you have your emergency
fund and yes obviously the house is the
next big thing so yeah run the numbers
and say okay let's say we paid it off
all you know and took the 60 grand
instead of a pool that but to me
it's 60 grand which actually is a
kind of a in ex like some pools i've
heard are like insane like yeah it's
crazy so
this is like a nice car this would be
like you know what i'm saying like the
60 grand so
if it was 200 000 michael i think my i
think my answer would probably be even
would be different
60 grand you have the cash for it
you got your 11 year old house
and we'll still have
honestly well over our three to six
month emergency fund how much do you
make a year did i how much do you make a
year all right
our base is 115 but with the bonuses
that my wife consistently gets we're
closer to about 120 okay pay your house
off faster maybe you split the
difference say i'll i'll get this but
we're going to put our house on on a 24
36 month payoff and so i'll trade you
the pool before we're hitting the gas
we're not going out to eat anymore we're
gonna get this house paid off and we're
gonna get it done and so then you both
when you look up in three years and you
both won
there you go
compromise this is the worst
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to
the ramsay show
so
john
hey listen i know you love it when
you're right study
i know you love it when you're right
so you are always i'm gonna just bash
just basketball actually you never you
never said i was wrong though oh no no
this is this is more american that would
have been better
i've watched you get beat up when we're
doing live events
and on the internets
on social media about
you always tell everybody we always tell
everybody to get joints
checking accounts and bank accounts and
don't hide money from me there was this
real instagram reel going around and it
was like you know basically say
something that no one would say out loud
and you like point and you put like a
thing and i put when you get married
combine your money including one
checking out and you would have thought
oh i yeah you would have thought that i
was like you're
you everyone out there i hate no you you
thought you put like you have to fight
your neighbor over for yeah yeah dude it
was you got some a lot of heat for it it
was like hey go drive to a red light and
whoever's next to you in the car combine
you're checking everyone's like you're
so stupid like you would've thought that
was my advice all right so i'll just say
gladstone garbinski
mogan learn
mog and lindner sorry that i just
butchered your name
um in the journal of personality and
social psychology
this is the abstract um
ultimately
when couples decide to share their lives
their assignment simultaneously faced
with a decision of how or whether to
pool their finances so this group of
psychologists is doing a study to find
out
um does the way in which couples keep
their money affect happiness and their
relationship so they took the rachel
cruz
cruzism
the ramsayism and said we're going to
put it to the empirical test now they
did six different studies now i haven't
read the methodology here but so this is
just the abstract but
their sample size was almost 40 000
people including primary and secondary
which in your world a lot right that's a
lot
um so
again i haven't looked at the
methodology but here's what they came
across across six studies about 40 000
people that couples who pool all of
their money compared to couples who keep
all or some of their money separate
experience greater relationship
satisfaction and are less likely to
break up
joining bank account
though it can it benefits all couples
the effect is particularly strong among
couples with scarce financial resources
so empirically
if you will put all of your money in the
account and deal with all of the anxiety
and all of the hard conversations and
all the push and pull that that will
entail
the data says you're less likely to
break up and you are more likely to
experience greater relationships
and what else do we want in a marriage
to not break up and to experience
satisfaction in the marriage when we
talk about this a lot in money and
marriage but it's so in our event but
it's so funny to me and you're the one
that said it so i want to coin you but
i'm like
you will share a kitchen with someone
you will share a bed with someone you
share your your genetics
together
but when it comes to your checking
account that's my money no i earned it
no where's my 300 for the light bill
it's like what are you talking about
you know what i mean yes
it blows my mind and i do know people
have a lot of
trigger points and fear around it
because of past experiences right like
there is there's legitimate
people walk through legitimate pain and
hardship to get to that and to say i'm
too scared now to still go in
full force to my second marriage or
whatever maybe
but still okay so if you're choosing to
get married you guys if you're choosing
to share your life
and the reason you don't is another
reason is people say well we just fight
all the time we file time it's easier
just to avoid the conflicts but that's
the exact conflict you have to have yeah
to have to have a better marriage you're
just avoiding it and when you're
avoiding that you're probably avoiding
other things right
like if if your thought is i can't ever
have that conversation it's just getting
in a fight or i can't ever talk to him
or her about this because it would
then don't get married
do not get married because that that gap
in communication that gap in
the ability to have hard conversations
and do hard things together will show up
somewhere and there's going to be kids
involved or there's going to be a
mortgage or a business involved there's
going to be in-laws involved it only it
only magnifies from there so if the
thought of sitting down with somebody
you're dating or engaged to and saying
hey it's a big deal to me that when we
get married we pull all of our money
together if you can't do that call it
call it because what's coming for you is
going to be worse and worse and worse
and worse okay so for people that are
married though and that this is still a
point they're like yeah you know i i had
a
dm come through
someone slid into your dms
and i don't always check it but i was
just home and i was like going through
them and she was like yeah i'm thinking
about getting a separate checking
account for just my spending
um because he kind of harps on what i
spend my money on and i'm kind of just
tired of it so we do everything else we
budget together that but just my
spending i want a separate account
and i messaged her back i was like hey
no
no because the issue is not having a
separate account the issue is that your
husband's either being kind of a jerk
and and poking at you and bringing up
things in the past to throw in your face
that you've spent
or
maybe what you're spending y'all aren't
agree on and he's frustrated like i
don't know who's right or wrong it
sounded like you know she was more right
but obviously she was going to dm me but
i was like no you can't don't put a
band-aid of things on your relationship
and that's what people i feel like do
all the time we'll just figure out
systems and marriage
with our money so that we don't have to
like go there we have to engage we don't
have to we don't go there and i'm like
go there go there it's painful and it's
hard
but it's worth it like that
that's a deeper marriage and finding out
as much as you love somebody that
they're not going to be your forever
person because they can't honor your
safety before you get married
call it right and if you are with a
spouse who steadfastly refuses to join
then here's how much you've got to go
connect with somebody that's when you
call and say i'm going to go start
seeing somebody i'd love for you to join
me because this marriage isn't safe
because you don't trust me we don't
trust each other enough here and you and
i both heard of of
people who blow all the money because
they've got addictions who blow all the
money because like well i just need a
new rifle it's like well yeah but we
need diapers it's like well you can
figure that out yeah everybody knows of
that and so we're not talking about
those there's a small percentage
yes yes or there's yeah an addiction
with gambling or yeah something else yes
there's a lot of people most of the time
yes
put your money in the same account yes
yes right and here we won't keep harping
on this but but another thing too that i
would love to for you to speak on though
is that there's i hear for women
especially don't depend on a man like
like it is sell independence is
celebrated where it's like oh no i can
take care of myself i don't have to you
know and that idea
that can rot a marriage as well right
this idea that i'm going to continue to
stay separate from you to take care of
my own self
that's still a level a guard that's up
that you're not allowing
terry reel who i consider america's
greatest therapist he's just
extraordinary he's a great author um
he says that the great lie that women
were told coming out of the 50s and 60s
and 70s is
you don't need anybody and you can do
this all by yourself and the great lie
that men were told is the rules didn't
change because the rules did change
and your wife got a seat at the table
when i was doing research for my book
yeah my mom who got married in
70 was not allowed by law to go get her
own checking account without my dad's
signature until 73
wow this is our parents right this is
the arc of our parents relationships i
blew my mind right so the rules changed
for men and women men have to have to do
things differently yes they have to be
more inclusive they have to sit at the
table they have to have hard
conversations they have to invite
partners into these conversations in
ways that they that their grandparents
didn't yeah
and the lie that you know what you can
do all of this by yourself is not true
we're not wired that we're not built
that way and that's not woo that's
co-regulated science that's who we are
we got to do life together yeah so you
guys i mean here are seg plays i know
we're kind of like
you know harping on this topic but for
real it's hard man
the money and marriage conversation it
is it's so tough because your marriage
issues come out in all different ways
and money is one of those avenues it
comes out through money and so there can
be tension there can be fights
but digging in and working on what's
really going on underneath the surface
and and seeing yourself as a team inside
and you both come to people that's right
like i you know sometimes it's all put
on the woman and it's like yeah because
she's the one that's doing a lot of the
household spending and all that we see
that in studies and so for some women
they feel very isolated because their
husband's not helping he's not engaging
in the conversation or the flip is my
dad did it i'm doing it and the flip is
not that yeah i'm just i'm gonna just
you know yield to him and he can just no
you have a voice too step in and you
guys working together you're going to be
different opposites attract so be
prepared for that we we both feel bad
uh
in our marriages but but man i'm telling
you combine this your marriage has to be
so tightly unified and use money as a
tool to be one of those things that that
helps
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i am
ramsay personality rachel cruz along
with dr john deloney and
we are pumped america because
we're coming we're coming for you we are
now hitting the road sounds so dramatic
for live events coming for you
for when you when it was part of your
job for 10 years and then you can't do
events for two because of the old covid
now it's back events are back and we are
back and we are so excited so our
building wealth live event is coming to
vegas
in orlando disney world i mean my two
favorite yeah two favorite places is
great uh if you want to see wheels off
rachel you can see rachel in vegas or in
orlando or at disney we get them both i
can't wait
but we uh are traveling out with this
event building wealth because it's such
a hot topic because i feel like there's
so many options people are talking about
getting wealthy whether it's crypto or
single stocks or zero down real estate
pokemon cards ah everything all of them
it's like everyone just wants to get
rich quick so dave ramsey george
campbell dr john deloney ken coleman
we're all going to unpack all of these
topics and
you and ken are actually going to be
doing a a free
bonus lesson before the event and talk
about balance of your work and
relationships and live a richer life
which sounds awesome so fun so vegas
we're coming for you on thursday may 5th
orlando may 19th and again we're so
excited because we actually have
confirmed
uh four more cities for the fall of the
same event so we're pumped about it but
again for here in the spring vegas you
are thursday may 15th in orlando
thursday may 19th you can get your
tickets starting at just 25
or get a four pack for 60 bucks
just go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more
all right coming up next is cliff from
indianapolis hey cliff welcome to the
show
hi rachel hi john what's up
well
i am
wanting some advice on how i can
work with my parents on taking care of
some of their debt that
my sister and i have discovered that
they have
and
my
father he's kind of the one that takes
control of finances and
when i explain to him
the baby steps and
financial peace he kind of grunts and
groans
doesn't really want to change his ways
and so
i'm just trying to figure out how do you
go about that working with
parents that
yes have some financial issues yeah it's
a great question cliff how old are you
how old your parents
my parents are in their early 70s
um i'm late late 40s okay
and what did you guys discover you said
you got you and your sister discovered
some debt that they've had
yeah uh credit cards uh personal loan
um
i think there's a time share
uh yeah that they're paying on
so a bunch of stuff and and they have
not come to you
stressed out or anything you're just
seeing all this and thinking oh gosh
they're they're not in a great spot
right yeah
so it's been my experience it's been my
experience that on two issues
parents do not receive
advice from their kids very well
sex and money
if you happen to show up at christmas
and you're 35 and your parents are 70
you're like
mom
here's how you're gonna you need to
start wooing debt she'll just cut you
off and be like how about you go out and
sleep in the yard right so they're not
gonna hear that and the same is hey you
know what y'all should be doing with
your money
for most parents your dad knows how much
daddy has and he knows the mess he's in
he he knows the math he knows it and
when his son comes to him a son who
loves him and who cares about him is
trying to do the best for him
it's such a shame inducing conversation
that every every response mechanism he
has to deflect that shame kicks off
right the grunts right the uh-huh
whatever house right your mother just
though all that stuff
is his body saying
i know i know i know i know i know and
it's too big and it's too late and i'm
scared
okay here's the hard part my experience
has been there's not a lot of movement
there the one thing you can do is to
have a conversation about
um
connectivity here's what i mean
hey dad um let's go to breakfast hey
i've had some success with this stuff
if you ever need something i want you to
know i've made some stupid errors too
that you don't even know about and i'm
i'd love to be a first call and i love
you and i love mom and i want y'all to
live to be 140 years old
if you need anything when it comes to
talking about money i'm an open book and
i'll help in any way i can
and that makes it more of a connection
conversation a relationship conversation
and less about a failure or you didn't
do the x's and o's right you hear the
difference it's subtle but it's massive
right yeah and it makes sense other than
that man
it's tough i know yeah that is yeah
that's what i was going to say though is
i feel like
any conversation that i hear that is
successful between a child to a parent
and that is them just sharing their own
experience the child right and just
saying hey
here's what here's what we've done and
it's it's been amazing and the benefits
of being debt-free and having this
emergency fund like it just takes it
took so much stress off that i didn't
even realize and we're just really
pumped about it and hey dad if you guys
ever yeah i have a question or anything
i would love to sit down talk because
yeah we've i've seen the flip side of
this
and now that or even i don't know if
this is would be another avenue to cliff
but because of their age
talking to parents about their estate
and their will like all of that which
kind of gets into a different type of
conversation because we're talking about
death as well but but just the idea of
hey we want to honor your legacy and
what you and mom have built over the
years of over our life and so
whenever you want to dive into that the
more details me and your sister you know
can have around that to to honor you
guys if something were to happen like we
want to know that and be on the same
team with you all so that could be
another door that's actually a great um
and i
it's one of those things i forget all
the time because my dad was a homicide
detective we've been talking about death
we we talk way too much our family nurse
can be uncomfortable once a year
family meeting at the ramsey's so if
that guy dies right um that's actually a
brilliant idea cliff is just call your
dad and say or maybe send him a text and
say i'm gonna call you this week um need
to talk will
and that way he's got a moment to he's
got a day or two or three to wrap his
head around this conversation
and then say hey um
i had a buddy whose parents passed away
i just saw something on tv it's just
been something that's been in my soul i
want to make sure that you and i are on
the same page with how i'm going to take
care of mom if and when something
happens to you i want to make sure that
we've got it all down that if something
happens to mom that we are going to
honor you and love you and honor her the
best way we can and can we sit down and
talk wills and i don't care about who's
in the will or who's i don't care any of
that stuff i just want to make sure
we're honoring you guys the right way
some parents take that again oh they're
just after our stuff you can't control
that what you're trying to do is on the
front end honor and love your parents
the best you can you can't control what
how they choose to internalize it yeah
that's right all right up next is is it
bovick
is that right from raleigh did i say it
right
yeah you said it right what's up man
welcome to the show how can we help
yeah i want to say thank you to guys
i've been following you guys for a while
now and i learned a lot of things from
you guys um today i'm calling uh
to get an advice on a situation that i'm
having
so my mx account was charged off on
december 2020
and
the collection agency um
it seems like i'm not able to find that
listing in my recent credit report
um so i'm wondering is it worth paying
off that collection when you're trying
to reach out to the agency and you know
working up a deal with them
yeah that is the collection are they are
they actively calling you as of now
they haven't called me i would say since
last
six months in the last six months and
how much do you owe on it
i owe them 3 400 3 400. and it's not on
your credit report
no
i saw experian and trans union credit
report
neither of them has that listing
and you can you go back in your own
records and know that you had 3 400 on
the cmx
yeah because the mx they do report to
the credit bureau and i see that you
know they have charged off on december
2020 and the amount was 3 400
okay so whenever it's in collections you
know depending on on where you're at in
it you can definitely try to just settle
it even for pennies on the dollar so
yeah i think i would definitely go in
and just call them and see if you can
settle it and they may have they may
have sold it off to somebody else at
this point and they may say that it's
gone and they're gonna we have to wait
for a letter well john so fun co-hosting
with you today thank you america for
listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
ramsey at personality rachel cruz
alongside of me today is dr john deloney
and we're here to answer your questions
to talk about your money your life your
relationships anything and everything so
up first we have kevin out of denver hey
kevin welcome to the show
hey guys how are you doing doing great
how can we help
um
i think i have the answer to it i just
want some validation maybe getting ahead
of ourselves a little bit but
we are on track to be out of debt in
august
with the recent change here which is
what i'm calling about our youngest son
is
signed up to start his diesel mechanics
program
and he'll be starting in june and we're
going to cash flow that tuition
but the question comes down to
moving from baby step two to three with
the six-month fund
and this tuition so
we have more than enough to cash flow
the tuition
um
the question is do i
or do we
um save the money all for the tuition
which is about 35 000. um and pay that
in you know as large
trunks as we can
or do we pay the monthly tuition which
is about twenty seven hundred
and put towards the six month
um emergency fund
the way we always answer these questions
kevin is if i were to wake up in your
shoes tomorrow you know what what would
i do and if you have enough money
to be able to say yeah let's do the
monthly installments and save up for the
emergency fund that's that's the route i
would take absolutely 100
the chances of something of the chances
of something
going sideways the chances of
your son changes his mind halfway
through and he wants to go through
another program or something like that i
just worked with college students
forever everybody changes their major
everybody changes their interest not the
best thing that's going to happen but i
would much rather see
um
him have some skin in the game you guys
have an emergency fund and let's take
this one step at a time yeah and kevin
it's i mean it's such a noble and
honorable thing to help your kids with
school right anything beyond high school
to say hey we're going to be able to
help assist you financially as a gift
that's a huge gift
um but i also you know when we do the
baby steps that that ends up being baby
step five where you
already have you and your wives
everything is settled or you have a
solid financial foundation of an
emergency fund you're funding retirement
all that before you get to this step
so you're jumping ahead you're jumping
ahead a little bit on on the basis now
if you're able to kind of cash flow it
and keep that in your expenses uh you
can but also
you know your son i mean he he can get a
part-time job too he can help you know
throw some money at this um because i do
want you guys that to be stable because
if something were to happen kevin and
you guys don't have that emergency fund
then you're in an unstable situation he
then is an unstable situation because
he's not getting his monthly stipend
from you guys that he's used to all of
that you know what i'm saying so having
more
of a foundation there would feel good so
even if you said hey we're gonna pay for
the first two months
son we if you're able to put put some
money aside so that by that third month
you have money as well while we're
saving up you know you guys can kind of
go out at a team effort but that's a
very generous
team effort from you kevin i just want
you to hear that um that you you don't
have an obligation to pay for your stuff
if you have the money it's awesome how
do y'all feel about him having some skin
in the game participating in the payment
you know
we
we definitely want that i mean he's
he um we you know we we cashflowed his
brother's four-year tuition and you know
so we
we did that and he did they do work
during the summers and that's our thing
has always been look you know as long as
there is commitment and good grades
and you are working you know when
school's not in session
then you know that's what we were you
know
willing to do and he is working now he
has you know some money in savings and
so
you know the plan is hey that's you know
not below your money to blow now that's
money to go towards your gas and other
expenses and what have you as you're
going through the program so
so so i i would i would
go ahead go ahead i'll just say
i would articulate those things
and sit down and say hey here's what i'm
going to do tell them here i got the
money and i'm going to make sure our
whole family is financially secure and
here's what you're teaching him you're
teaching him how you handle money which
is a gift and of itself i'm filling up
our emergency fund so that we're all
safe we all have food we all have bills
no matter what what happens and then
here's how we're going to do college
my expectation for you is that you take
care of gas you take care of insurance
you take care of your food
right let's be very clear the number of
college students like no no my mom's got
it and then mom calls me and it's like
no i i uh you know sons got it man that
clarity can be so much and you're right
skin in the game man if
it means different things for different
people in different places sometimes
scaring the game is grades and sometimes
i'll take care of the money you make
sure you make good grades and yeah
sometimes that you pay for a semester
and otherwise but every week but just
gotta have the clear conversation yes
because it's not a it's not a work ethic
conversation for me and your son i mean
you know
kevin he may have a great work ethic so
it's not like i know we have to instill
this by making him pay i just want to
make sure kevin that you and your wife
are in a good spot that you guys have an
emergency everything because if
something comes up
then everyone's kind of out so um but
it's a great great question kevin thanks
up next we have dylan from greensboro
hey dylan welcome to the show
hey uh rachel how are y'all doing great
how can we help
i just got a question with uh paying off
a truck really not sure
which way to go
um i've got picked up i currently owe
about 23 000 on it okay and um
i have about fifteen thousand dollars
saved and i actually have a couple toys
that i really don't want to part with
but that might be a way i need to go
maybe so okay dylan how much do you make
a year
uh
roughly from 55 to 68 000. okay and then
what other debt do you have
that's it what toys that's
uh
i have a side beside my motorcycle and
i'm leaning on selling the side-by-side
how much is it worth i can't
uh probably 16 to 18 000. okay
today
yeah so dylan let me tell you this our
rule of thumb is not to have more than
half of your annual income on that have
a motor and wheels attached to it okay
so you're already bumped up bumping
above all of that with that side by side
motorcycle this you got anything else
with wheels and a motor
uh i have a camry that i'm also selling
oh how much can you get for that
uh four or five okay
okay and see that that's my question uh
i'm trying to figure out do i pretty
much deplete my bank account and pay it
off with the car and then use my taxes
to pay off the rest
and
keep all the other toys or do i sell the
side-by-side and keep some money in my
pocket yep uh if i were you i'd sell the
side by side i would sell the civic
whatever remaining left take out the 15k
and then whatever's left of the 15k
is your emergency fund that you're going
to continue to build on but you got a
lot of wheels you don't make enough
money motor for your income dylan but
get rid of it all keep the truck pay it
off you're good to go
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to
the ramsay show
hey rachel this is a big shocker
uh
[Music]
you're you're more fashionable than me
right
i mostly wear t-shirts in black dress
shirts over and over and over i'm gonna
say correct john colony correct you're
bejeweled and bedazzled
so all right i need you to help me with
something because there's a thing going
on in the americas in the world that i
don't i literally don't understand and i
it's in the new world it's it's yes yes
it's in the internet literally a new
world is what it feels like so here's
what this uh here's what the gosh here's
what the the article says imagine it's
20 50. you're walking around times
square in a puffer jacket
nope i'm just going to stop right there
and say no but i'll continue
made of pixels and the code that made
the matrix itself you look cool in the
green fit to say the least i'm going to
go i'm going to disagree you don't look
cool but continue
you've even paired this out of the world
garment with some dark shades to elevate
the wow factor what if i told you it
already exists in the digital world and
you could wear it
rachel
not only am i not cool in regular world
in real world
in america
i'm not cool on the internet world where
i guess i have another life where i can
buy
digital fashion
i guess it became through skins with
gamers it's a 40
billion dollars
to buy clothes we could solve hunger in
america
with less than money than that than
people who buy
imaginary clothes in an imaginary world
with swords and dragons and stuff now
listen adidas armani calvin klein have
dabbled in digital fashion
what is happening what is happening i
don't know i don't know i don't know the
metaverse conversation i don't under i
really don't get it i will say we bought
an oculus
yeah
and you put that thing on oh it's tr
it's a trick it is the weird it's one of
the weirdest experiences yes
that i've ever had because you kind of
live in it for whether you're on a
roller coaster or we got we did a bar
fight yeah i got i got an innocuous
fistfight like oh my gosh and you get
and i get scared i mean i get i get
physically scared you feel like you're
there and then you take off your goggles
you're like
i'm just in my living room it's just so
weird it's so weird so but so that's
that's that's as much as i've dabbled in
the is that considered the metaphor
that's considered the metaverse right i
think that's the the controlled version
that's not the like live-in version
but again you're asking a guy that says
i i feel i want to buy a cow
you know what i'm i want to figure out
how i can fix my fencing so i can buy a
real cow
that exists in the real world that makes
real cow plops and it like makes real
milk that's what i'm looking to spend my
money on it never occurred to me to
think you know what you could buy a fake
cake i've got enough armani in the real
world i want some i want some digital my
calvin klein section of my closet's
really overflowing so i'm actually going
to go digital
i don't get i don't know this is but the
metaverse is eight is gonna be 800
billion dollars by 2024
according to bloomberg
what do you do in it that like where's
this money you're crazy you create a
person do we sound so sick i may sound
so stupid right now i feel very ignorant
here's what's awesome so you so you have
do i have me there is like is my is it
my face or i make up a new person
whatever you want to be
i said that in my creepiest metaverse
voice
yeah um here's what's cool digital
clothes don't require raw material duh
or labor or manufacturing or shipping
because they're not real
oh listen if you make a budget and you
have a line item for
i would like a digital fishing pole to
fish in my digital river and catch
digital fish go fishing
go fishing
are we gonna melt like as a culture
this is a culture that's got access to
not jesus coming back soon oh there you
go you have to go get all
no this is too much
this is our basic needs have been taken
care of and we have access to too much
capital you know what i will my husband
does not like to be the forefront of my
conversations on national radio slash
youtube slash podcast
but winston says that all the time like
when something big like blows up he's
like because we literally don't have to
go out and get food and spend our energy
finding clean water somewhere in the
world like like we we have everything
taken care of so it's like we're bored
are we just bored with our real lives
that this is what's happening or we have
become so anxious and we're unwilling to
deal with the discomfort we've
pathologized discomfort to the point
that we're creating a whole new world
um so social media like doesn't even
doesn't even scratch the surface of this
stuff this is like a whole other yeah
it's it's an immersive
other world it's it's wall-e yeah it's
it's just another
it's so great plain so here's what i
would suggest for it be work let's let's
live here let's live here let's be well
here yes if you're going to spend money
spend it on real things um and again
playing video games that's real that's
fun it's entertainment sure it's not a
place to
enter into what i mean
and hey in five or ten years if i'm
wrong i'll be the first to tell you i'll
screw this up you know i'll be the first
if we have fpu in the metaverse and i
think we probably i mean honestly this
is where life is going don't you want to
meet people where they're going nope i
don't know it's a bit this is a business
conversation
i want to go to the woods i don't know i
mean i'm going to get a cow and another
dog you're right get off my lawn
yeah
ginseng or zoo millennials whoever's
here you know what i would love for a
ball to just mysteriously fly into my
yard because that would mean kids are
outside playing with one with a real one
with the real ball not if a digital ball
comes on my digital line i'm gonna pop
it
let let's ask the next caller if she had
500 if she will buy clothes in the
metaverse the next caller is a travel
nurse she's not she's natalie from
milwaukee natalie welcome to the show
hi how are you good well you if we gave
you 500 would you spend it on digital
clothing in the metaverse
[Music]
hey and i see it on the screen you're a
travel nurse that means you deal in
reality every day real body like real
people
real blood
so you you get to wash the clothes okay
so
how can we help
um i just wanted to uh first of all mr
uh dr john delonge i recently purchased
your book i'm really excited to get it
thank you thank you thank you
um i had a question about
being a travel nurse's spouse we're in a
new city
away from family friends
and i feel like i'm holding my own
pretty well
going to the gym exercising have a
church family here
basically my day-to-day tasks i um
take care of our dogs go grocery
shopping if i need to fix dinner
exercise with my husband at night
um
but i feel like my mental health isn't
going so well i've struggled with it in
the past
um
definitely i know the steps that need to
be taken
um
probably the lack of social
social interaction is one of the biggies
but what what suggestions would you
might have for someone in my situation
um
that's such a great great great question
and with so much mobility happening in
the country right now people moving and
changing jobs and then the last study
they just got there and now they want to
move again
thank you for asking this question it's
going to help a whole bunch of people
okay the first thing is if you've got
past mental health challenges that
you've worked through
one of the first things i would do when
you move to a new community set up you
know find out where the dentist is and
find out where the your primary care
physician is going to be but
find a local counselor that you trust um
or if if you're able to if you're in the
same state and you can keep the um one
and you can meet up electronically make
sure you've got that anchor point okay
and that's for dealing with any of the
mental health challenges that you've
struggled with in the past
this is going to sound counterintuitive
but i want you to act like you're going
to live there forever
i want you to develop
develop relationships and friendships
because you've got a brain right now
that's screaming for connection
and it's hard with shallow roots because
there's a part of you that wants to make
friends and connect and hey what's up
once y'all come to dinner and there's
that other lingering part that knows
we're about to move anyway
i want you to not live that way invite
people over to your house be hospitable
go first take a risk say hey y'all want
to come have coffee and if they say no
that's because they've got things in
their life it's not a reflection of you
go first go first go first make it a
regular part of your calendar a regular
part of your week
and hang on to those relationships and
do it again in the next city and do it
again after that we'll be right back
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at ch
ministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to
the ramsay show and our last caller
mentioned it john but she said she
pre-ordered your new book which is so
exciting own your past
change your future that makes two sales
my mom and the last caller that's so
exciting natalie and natalie
oh so glad but you can pre-order
uh again today it's april 4th and you
get the free ebook
they'll just ship it to you today
two weeks before the book is available
to the public i know i find that i find
out about that on friday they didn't
they don't run any of this bias that's
amazing yeah that's great that's amazing
um okay so i wanna i wanna hear from you
because we haven't even really taught i
mean i haven't heard yeah i mean i know
about it obviously but i like me and you
have not really talked about the book
and books are exciting they really all
if you have
a message that you're like man i just
want more and more people to hear this a
book is a great way to do it right um
okay so for you what was the like what's
the motivation what's about what tell me
all your thoughts are on it if the
number of people that i get i get calls
all over the place all over the country
for people hey would you be my counselor
would you be my coach would you sit with
me my wife whatever and i can't do that
um if i was to sit down with somebody
across the table for several hours and
listen
and
ask questions
and ultimately end up somewhere this is
what that book is right this is so good
ten years of uh in the making it's me
walking with a whole bunch of people
over the last few years including that
ugly
idiotic guy that i see in the mirror
every morning
and figuring out what is happening to me
to my marriage to my friends marriages
to our culture to this country what is
happening
and how do we reverse engineer this man
because i got two little kids staring at
me and so that's this book man it's and
um somebody brought this up in an
interview and i'm glad they did it
i've read a thousand
mental health books and relationship
books and they're all so good there's a
bunch of great stuff out there
but the thing i wanted to make this book
different is i'm not talking at you in
this book i'm i'm walking with you in
this one so it's not another mental
health book you know not everybody needs
them in a whole book nobody needs a new
relationship this is me walking
alongside you and i don't care where you
are in your life i've had
seven-year-olds read it and i've had um
middle schoolers in high schools read it
and they all said man i feel like you
were walking with me in this deal and
that's that's the highest praise i can
get at this point for sure well and
there's there's so much to be said
number one i feel like we're a culture
that's shifting well you've lived in
this world the counseling world and
everything for years but i feel like we
are shifting as a culture
to become more comfortable with hey i
kind of figure out and dig into why am i
the way i am everything from your past
right under all that
to just become and i hate the word i
mean healthy i feel like it's thrown
around so often but it is it's to become
a healthier whole person because it
affects everything in your life it
affects the way you parent if you're
married your spouse it affects your
friendships it affects your work
everything and so being able to kind of
dig into that i think is is massive in
this book yeah i mean it's for
if you're single it's for if you're
right out of college it's if you're
married it's if you're in your 70s like
everyone everyone could take something
away from this book in this conversation
so it's so good so um on your past
change your future dr john deloney
pre-order your copy today you guys
ramsay solutions.com all i know is told
me he got tears
and i didn't know that was possible
well i'll be honest he cries more oh man
i thought i had something he tries more
than my mom i thought
he does great rachel i'm sorry i was
like man sorry i called my mom and i was
like mom i made dave cry she was like
wow and rachel's like oh he does that
all the time yeah and in movies like i'm
going to see jack frost the movie with
the snowman oh he was like
in the scene next to me i was like dad
it's about a snowman isn't it i like the
[ __ ] i cried the other day in a movie
and my daughter
what movie was it um
sing two oh it's so good dude it's so
great it's so good but i have a what
part of the movie
that song i still haven't found what i'm
looking
for she's out there a little porcupine
no forget porcupine when the lion comes
out of theater oh cause he's he's he's
he's changing his future
he owned his past
and he changed his
and my future six i i think she was like
what did i do what did i say what did i
do why is dad crying and then i told her
i said sometimes um i cry movies like
that made me sad and it made me hopeful
for him made me sad for him and she said
sometimes i get sad and chose too dad
and like she was trying to come for me
that's so beautiful but yeah i cried
oh well it's a good one well thanks for
doing that for me and a good book i'm
sorry i don't mean
it's so funny dave
he will he's a crier sometimes and he
loves babies that's another thing that
people don't know about dave ramsey i do
too gosh give dave an infant and he's
i do takes takes the baby from you takes
the baby from you and holds the baby so
funny okay up next we have jennifer from
dayton hey jennifer welcome to the show
hi guys i'm so happy to be with you
thanks for calling how can we help
okay so um we went through the financial
peace university a couple years ago and
i'm excited to say we are on baby step
three savings nice
emergency phone congrats
thank you and i've done the math because
i'm a planner and i know it's going to
take us 24 months to fully fund that for
six months and i'm very excited about
that
so looking past that i'm like okay so
then baby step four five and six
is you know put ten percent to
retirement 10 to our kids college fund
and then or 15 i'm sorry and then
anything left over you know pay down the
house
and so then i've done that i've crunched
the numbers and i'm like okay well
that's an extra 13 000 for retirement an
extra 13 000 for college where am i
supposed to get that extra 26 000 a year
from
i mean if all of our bills in two years
is exactly the same as right now
i just don't know where that extra
money's supposed to come from yeah no
it's a great question well the money
that you're saving now for your
emergency fund obviously will be freed
up and how much 400 a month so i
definitely have put that that'll go into
that but then i'll need an extra 600.
you know get it up to the you know 10
083 for the retirement and yeah i'm
sorry one thousand eighteen the time and
one thousand eighty-three for the
college yeah how much extra for the
house jennifer how much do you guys make
a year
ninety thousand ninety thousand
where did you get the number fifteen
percent for college
um for from dave ramsey's book because i
just finished it from the financial
piece i reread it i mean i read it years
like i went to the university but i just
reread it now and it said um you know 50
for retirement 50 for college and then
anything extra pay on the house
yeah i don't know
i could be wrong jennifer but i want to
say i don't think we put a percentage
with kids college i've never heard it he
may have put in the book i'd go back and
check that because yeah this is the book
i'm looking at it right now okay
my guess is if you are
if you have the ability to to do that
because i'm gonna tell you you may have
to sit down and say okay 15
for our budget is not is
we're gonna have to have different
conversations about college
because
that's just gonna be a hard reality in
our home
um not every family can put that type of
money down for college yeah how many
okay how many kids do you guys have and
how old are they
we've got an eight-year-old and a
two-year-old okay
so you yeah you have time on the college
aspect so i would say your first focus
is that 15 into retirement because i
want you guys to start you know funding
your 401ks roth iras all of that to be
at a point that when you do want to
retire that you have the ability to so
that's obviously first and foremost um
yeah and then any money i'm going to
step away from the 15 from kids college
because for some reason i don't know why
i'm not i'm not
i don't remember it being that hard of a
line i know your retirement has to be
because after the math and all of that
over years and decades like that that's
about how to keep your lifestyle the
same at retirement um when you guys
start but that the kids college thing
you may just kind of want to tap your
brakes on number one you're you have
time
uh to fund that stuff um so i would i
would probably tap my breaks get
comfortable with all of that once you
start funding your 15 to retirement
it'll come out of your paycheck if
you're if you're working your your
company has a 401k um
so just so get comfortable like a month
or two with that right three months and
then look up and say okay how is it
because hopefully in two years too
jennifer you know the hope is over the
course of your career that you're going
to be
getting raises that you guys will get
bonus you know what i'm saying that like
you'll be at a place
um that you'll be hopefully growing in
your career and making more money
10 years from now than you are today
especially with the inflation being as
crazy as it is i'm like we're already
losing money right now right
now in your retirement
in your retirement you're hanging there
i i would rather you
i hate i hate to go against the
the tmmo bible here i i would love to
see you just have a number we want to
have twenty five thousand dollars we
won't have a hundred thousand dollars
and you can reverse engineer that for
college yeah absolutely yeah
i want 200 000 so they can go to any
school they want or we're going to
reverse engineer this thing yeah yep
absolutely so yeah take your time
jennifer breathe it's okay but that 15
for retirement is gonna be your number
one goal this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one retailer online retailer
for custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you save even more so use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from ethan in south dakota ethan
writes my wife and i have been married
for two years and are in baby step three
we agreed that we would have my
mother-in-law our last living parent
live with us when she needs care as she
ages rather than putting her in a
nursing home
with a nudge from us she has just
started contributing 40 a month to her
company 401k
she is 55 years old and earns between 15
to 20 an hour and we have mentioned it's
important to start contributing now to
help her offset her retirement costs
we're happy to help contribute into
mutual funds however she does not seem
to feel the same urgency we do
any thoughts on how we can get her to
contribute to her own upkeep
number one don't refer to your
mother-in-law as a lawn mower she's not
she's not her own upkeep
like
she's not like an appliance
um but yes just yeah don't don't use the
word own upkeep okay
her own
well i think i think it's hard to make
someone have a sense of urgency
that they don't have themselves right
psychologist dr john well so number one
she's making 15 to 20 bucks an hour
she's an hourly employee
and she doesn't have a lot of money to
begin with right so this sounds like
it's a practice more than a principle
the second thing is i want to go back to
what y'all decided early here early
early here in your marriage
when she needs us we'll be there that's
where the period at the end of that
sentence is y'all have made a value
statement on that's a cornerstone of
your relationship y'all made it early on
if this then we will right fill in the
blank and so now you're just talking
about what kind of contribution what
kind of
what kind of extra support is going to
be in there because you've already made
a values choice um
man you're right you can't i mean what
are you going to say hey you're going to
die someday and we want you to take more
of your already incredibly limited thing
or you need to get another job and make
more money right it i mean you can sit
down and have those conversations those
are going to be hard and they're all
going to come to or what right like or
what are you going to really not take
her in
right those are just hard and they're a
recipe for
fighting and for hey why are you
spending money on that i mean you know
what i mean it's just because it's a
caustic relationship mess yep absolutely
so that boundary they set yeah you think
has created like a or that door they've
opened i guess not really a boundary but
hey you can live with us
in the future and i i think they decided
that and what's important about it is
they decided it which means that they
are going to be responsible for taking
care of this thing
and it would be great if she came with a
million dollars in a 401 to help build
the addition on the house and to pay for
all the in-home nursing care and all
that it's not going to happen yeah it's
just not going to happen yeah so
i mean really yeah i mean i would
encourage her she needs a different job
i mean if she's 55 and doesn't have
retirement
and she's making 15 bucks an hour it's
not going to be sustainable like it's
just it's not so
um
she neither needs to find two more of
those or
find something different which is always
uncomfortable and i always kind of
hesitate and i don't know why
i'm so bad saying that because by the
time you're 55 you've had your you know
you've you've lived enough life that you
kind of feel like okay i should be good
now and when you change something as big
as a career it is uncomfortable and it's
not it's not fun but that's
i don't know i think it's like you have
to be able to you're gonna have to make
peace with y'all are going to be footing
the majority of this she's 55 she's
making 15 an hour she's making 40 a
month and it took a nudge from y'all
just to even get any sort of
contribution the other thing you can do
is sit down and say hey we'd love to
come up with a game plan with you would
you be willing to do that with us yes
and we want to talk about your will we
want to talk about your
long-term care insurance which is a big
thing um that you all can start spending
the
any number of hey let's map this thing
out so in 70 years here's how much we're
going to have we're going to call the
smart investor pro to sit down any of
those things could be hey we want to
just make sure we're all in the same
plan there's only you're our last living
parent and we want to honor and love you
the best we can
um but you're dealing with just math
here and at this current job
um that's just not going to go very far
that's right
all right up next we have mark from
wisconsin hey mark welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me guys absolutely
how can we help
a question for you in july i lost my job
and um
it's okay um
i have 600 000 in the for a traditional
401k there
so my question i'm able to leave it
there last year i made almost a hundred
thousand
um so should i leave it there
um
roll it over to my new job or we just
recently paid off our house
congratulations man
thank you sir
um or thanks guys um
we still have uh like 13 000 of debt on
a truck but otherwise we're debt-free um
so we started uh
just a normal ira through edward jones
um so my question is
should i leave my 401k where it's at
move it to my new job
or roll it over to
the other
company yes so rolling it over yeah to a
traditional ira sitting down with the
smart fester pro 2 will help you kind of
navigate all of that
but being able to
to yeah you could roll it over to the
new company but i would roll it over to
just the traditional ira leave it there
and start new with your uh with your
company but don't take any of that out
before the truck i heard you say
and you guys did awesome you have you're
completely you know you don't have a
mortgage or anything so you should be
able to knock out that truck payment but
do not
use any of that money for your debt so
here's what i did in my life so i've i
have had multiple jobs at multiple
different universities i call the smart
investor pro
they pulled all of them from the other
different places at this 401 here and
this 403 b over here we rolled them all
into
um
our my own individual retirement
accounts
and they split them up in the ways that
we teach here and then i've got another
one with ramsey solutions that's a
separate account right and that keeps
everything clean and simple and if not
if when dave fires me which let's be
honest um i will take what's here and
i'll roll that into the other one too
right yes yes hopefully it doesn't
matter
that's right that's right
all right we have karina from orlando
hey karina welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we help
um so my question is i am about forty
two thousand dollars in debt and i am
just starting the program now i'm in
baby step one welcome to the game
exciting yes
but um one of my looking at my you know
that um story here one of my desks is my
car loan which is about fifteen thousand
dollars right now okay and it is a used
i bought it used and it's already at 88
000 miles my question is should i just
sell the car you know
tackle that loan or get another car my
my concern is getting a feeder car and
then having a lot of maintenance issues
because you know i won't be able to
afford anything
um better and i don't have anything
saved correct yeah
what do you make a year karina
i made roughly about 72 000 72 okay yeah
the car is not a huge
uh
it's not a huge factor in that because
we we really say if you can pay it off
in 18 to 24 months
is really our rule of thumb and so for
you with your income i think you're
going to be able to do that
but you're going to want to do the debt
snowball so what what other debt is the
42 000
um mainly student loans some credit card
as well okay
and one one uh one in collections for
from an insurance company okay so that
car is kind of in the middle toward the
end
of your debt snowball okay yeah i mean
if i were you i i think it's fine i mean
if we were talking about a thirty
thousand 000
car loan i i would have a different
answer for you but at 15 000 i think you
can pay it off in 18 to 24 months
um
and and right now you know not that you
would make this a huge factor but it's
always something to think about that
specifically as we're speaking the
market is just insane with cars so
honestly uh having it the miles don't
scare me the 88 000 i think you're fine
um so if i were you i'd keep it pay it
off put in that snowball and and get an
extra job you can get that 72 up for a
short period of time as you're building
your starter emergency fund of a
thousand dollars
and then you're gonna be doing your debt
snowball the more that you can increase
your income for a short period of time
and decrease your expenses cut your
lifestyle the faster you're gonna be out
of those 42 000 and korean i think you
can do it i mean i think i think
24 months
your life is gonna look totally
different so i'm really really excited
for you
john fun hosting with you again for
another segment thank you america for
listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
i am ramsey personality rachel cruz
along side me today dr john deloney and
we're here to answer your questions all
about your money your life your
relationships
anything and everything we are here for
you so
we're gonna go right to the calls this
hour and jason in cleveland is up next
hey jason welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for having me absolutely
how can we help
yeah looking for another
set of ears on our on our situation so
my wife and i have 87 000
uh dollars left of student loans we had
200 to start the plan um we're paying
about 4 000 a month so we're
getting after it as best we think we can
um
we had a five month old along the way
now so wow congratulations
how long have you all been on this man
um about two years since we got married
what were the loans what'd y'all go to
school for
uh my wife's a veterinarian okay all
right
so you need some extra ears you said to
um
of encouragement what do you need
because you guys have been you've been
at this for a long time a long time
yeah it's a long haul and not really
sure if uh i i can't imagine a hourly
job would make much of a dent in our in
the progress that we are making so
are we just in the grind i guess and
need to finish this out or any other
suggestions on how to
yeah um the fact is better how much how
much you guys making a year
about 175 okay
and you have your 80 and you have 87
left
yep yep
yeah i mean
the this is kind of the part of the debt
snowball journey where it can be start
to feel a little defeating because the
normalcy of the sacrifice is like
setting in right like people that can do
it you know and they kind of do the shot
in the arm for nine months and it's like
we can do anything for nine months but
when you look at
six figures um
of debt it's a longer process and that's
why we kind of say it is that
marathon it's not a sprint did you run
some numbers were you yeah i was just
looking to see so
i've been there paying off six figures
of student loans and you're sending
these massive checks
and there's that feeling we make too
much money to be living like this
is that what y'all are feeling
yeah it's just exhausting and you're not
putting life on pause for four years
yeah and yeah i just really wanted i ran
the math so at your current payoff it's
four years here's another way you could
look at it
um so i get that when you're putting
four thousand dollars adding working
extra jobs to pay another thousand a
month can feel like
um a beating right
but if you think about it this way
every four of those you get a month back
right
so for every if you work extra jobs you
make another thousand bucks a month
every fourth one of those you've just
earned a free month
or you've got a head a month so it's
going to take you a little bit longer to
catch up but if you do it
four and then four and then four so you
see what i'm saying you're accelerating
your process and you're gonna be what is
that four months ahead by the time you
pay this off so
you'll have moved up and if you can do
more than a thousand bucks you're
talking you've moved up you've knocked
six months off by just getting an extra
thousand bucks what do you do for a
living man
i'm a pm in healthcare industry okay
man if there's a any possible way for
the two of you she can work on saturdays
pick up sunday shifts and you'll take
care of the more domestic stuff without
whatever that looks like for y'all
man i i would much rather here's what
here's what i did i took on an extra two
jobs my wife took on a second one and we
we
limited our expenses to basically zero
because i couldn't do four year sprint i
can't run that far
for that long and so we did everything
we could in short order to get it done
and so i think it's worth it to suck it
up and figure out what is a how can we
scratch and call our way to 1500 more
dollars a month and you're going to
knock off at least half a year if not
more yeah and it is it's it's that it's
the worst continuing
to be in it but what's hard too is it's
like that a little bit of the math game
you know like what you're saying we're
in the numbers of what you can but then
feeling defeated at the same time too
with the interest all of it right so
it's just like getting continuing that
almost anger toward the situation that
you're like i'm so done i'm so done and
because i'm not done i'm gonna channel
all that anger and get mad at it and and
get it out that much faster but it is
it's it is a it is a complete journey i
mean it is
you keep on going and going and it's day
in and day out and that the little
sacrifices they do
make a difference it's those little
things
is there a way to cut expenses right and
it's hard too jason you guys added a
baby in the mix too so i'm like your
whole world has been turned upside down
with this new little one in the home so
i'm like you're exhausted i mean all of
it so there's a lot of life we we hear
that and empathize with that
telling you to keep keep pushing keep
pushing but thanks for the call
all right next up we have kathy from
williamsburg virginia hey kathy welcome
to the show
hi rachel and dr john thank you so much
for uh for taking our call today
absolutely
uh what is my responsibility
um
especially in terms of starting a
probate process
so my mom
my mom died on uh friday evening i'm
sorry oh my gosh kathy like just just
over the weekend
just over the weekend sorry was it
expect was were you expecting it or was
it
unexpected let's just say she went
downhill quickly oh i'm so sorry kathy
my clean ticket on saturday was supposed
to go see her in the hospital
and then we got the call friday night
so
um my husband and i who are sitting with
me we've been uh day followers for
about five years
but the rest of my family is not
so
she did have a will
that was dated 2003
she has outstanding debt
minimal assets she has a a mobile home a
trailer that she's lived in okay
that um costs i don't know if it was
five thousand dollars when she bought it
she'll get a social security check here
of the middle of april
um
as i said my husband and i are our day
followers
her legacy drawer was essentially
three
grocery tote bags that were on a hook in
the bathroom
yeah in the trailer so going through all
that finding all of these this paperwork
my brother who lived with her
does have access to her debit cards and
her accounts
and
i i just i don't know
what i am supposed to do
here's what i want you to do i want you
to hang on the line and we're gonna go
to a break right here and we come back
from the break we're gonna unpack this
and we'll walk you through the step by
step yeah i am so so sorry hold on kathy
we'll be back with you okay this is so
sorry the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show our last
caller um we held her over on this break
but um kathy
your
mom just passed away on friday and you
and your husband are now kind of digging
through
everything that is
you know from your mom's estate figuring
out really um
where she is financially not really she
didn't really have much of what we would
say a legacy drawer which has all of
your um important documents so you guys
are in the process of grieving and
trying to help the situation um with
your family with your mom's passing
suddenly is that was that a fair recap
kathy
correct okay so kathy are you the
executor of the estate
so i'm looking at the
will and the documentation and there
doesn't seem to be any executor listed
okay
well that's fun
okay so here's what we're going to do
the first thing is we're going to
go through the funeral
we're going to spend all of our efforts
and energy on the grief process here are
y'all going to have a funeral
uh she wanted to be cremated okay so um
and then she's going to be
uh buried with my stepfather okay and uh
but y'all will have some sort of family
ceremony of some sort
there won't be a family ceremony it's um
yeah we're not from the area she's in
florida okay and um
so
first and foremost
please please
come up with some sort of thing great
invite a couple of friends over um if
any of your i know family can be
estranged and they can be spread out all
over the country and different levels of
relationship there i get that um
one of the most important things you can
do is have some sort of touchstone
whether even if it's just you and your
husband
that y'all write a letter to your mom
and you read it out loud over a sunset
um you'll go
light a fire and you throw some notes
whatever that is
have invite a couple of friends over to
have a glass of wine and cheers and play
your mom's favorite records whatever
that is even if you and your mom did not
have a great relationship it's important
to have a touchstone moment um
people always ask me should i just go
ahead and skip the funeral and i said
come hell or her water skip that funeral
so if you aren't going to have one i'm
going to look to you to say hey this is
something that we need to do the second
thing is um i think without an executor
well let me back up it doesn't sound
like there's anything there
so but it also sounds like you have
taken it upon yourself to go through
this walk me through why you're doing
that
you know i i spent
decades in the military and
you know that's what that's what you do
you take responsibility for
for taking care of these these loose
ends
do you have brothers and sisters that
are fighting you on it
oh
no
my brother is on disability he
he is really disengaged when we went to
the hospital the first thing he wanted
to do was go through her curse and get
her debit card and um okay
yeah so what i what you need to do with
the hospital are you still in connection
there or have you gone back home
we're still in florida right now okay
get multiple copies of the death
certificate from the hospital i'd get 10
copies it's just kind of a rule of thumb
because you're going to need to send
them to credit card companies into gas
company whoever
but i would notify the bank asap that
she is deceased in the to put a stop
action on the all cards
because they're gonna come looking for
that money okay so i would call the bank
put a stop on it and let the bank know
this isn't a a time for your brother to
run up run up the bank
and then i would call a probate lawyer
and say we've got a will here that my
mother passed away we have a will and
there is no named executor and we need
some help walking through this thing and
they'll help you file the petition with
the county and all that kind of stuff
okay
and then you'll take that death
certificate and you'll notice you'll
send notice to all the creditors and all
this stuff
at some point they may sell off the
depending how much she owes they may
sell off that trailer and sell off the
land and your brother's gonna have to
find another place to live they may not
who knows how much she owes and to whom
and all that right
kathy how does that how does how's that
hit you
yeah um i can go ahead and uh call the
probate lawyer and uh get something get
something going yeah and i think as much
as that you said there were three bags
hanging on the back of the door with
just loose ends and papers and all that
and as much as you can to go through and
as much detail
that you can find
to sit down because you'll want an
estate attorney as well um
to go through some of that and and kind
of walk through it all just so that you
you have a plan with as much detail as
you can bring always always is helpful
and i would let the probate attorney
know this is not a
nobody's leaving the estate with assets
this this is going to be an asset free
um dissolution of this estate and so
i'm not going to come in here you're not
going to make 10 000 off of us we need
to come up with a small fee that we can
help you untangle this and then we're
going to settle these debts then we're
going to move on
um and we're going to step away from
this and at some point your brother if
he is disabled and unable to act for
himself then you've got to figure out
what comes next there um if you take
over
power of attorney for him and medical
power and all that kind of stuff if he's
disabled but he still receives uh his
social security check and he's still or
disability from the military he's still
doing his thing
then you and your husband grieve
but please don't leave florida without
some sort of small
ceremony some sort of touchstone that
y'all can start there
and then we'll settle this thing and
head back home and i'm so so sorry
um rachel what
the number of times i sat with somebody
the nuts and bolts of a loved one
passing is so hard because because that
that phone bill still comes and that
electric bill still comes and
it's just like somebody hit you in the
face and hit you it just keeps coming
and then the poor people who sold you
tires three years ago will send you
something that says hey
so and so your tires are
due to be rotated and you think they're
not even here you know what i mean that
kind of stuff just is the worst not to
mention
how do you sell the house and how do you
it's just so hard
to have a clear
will yeah so i would say a couple things
you guys listening um it's like these
conversations are always difficult when
you're talking about death and
especially you know when it's unexpected
um
but
to to remember that there are things you
can do now for your family to love them
really well if something were to happen
to you and i think i love what she said
of just taking this responsibility she's
taking this on for her mom
um but if you're listening things that
you can do you know we call it we call
it the legacy drawer but to really
though if you haven't tonight sit down
and find
all of the important documents that you
need that if something were to happen
your spouse your family member your
grown kids anyone can pull out a drawer
that there is a file and everything is
right there that you're not going
through and finding all these random
places and and half of it's not there
and it's a bank you know place over here
you know a security deposit box and you
don't know what you know i mean it can
just be a disaster because to the point
that
if something were to happen the grief
process is so huge just emotionally the
toll it takes on you losing someone that
you love
and then you're having to throw into
like these logistics what she's not even
you know she's three days yeah
and and she's having to sit here and
think about attorneys all like it's just
it's just hard so anything you can do on
this side
to really help set your family up is
really to love them well and here's
here's what a legacy box there's digital
ones now they're coming out that are
amazing and awesome
an old school one like i have in my
house like my dad's got in his house so
i got a fireproof box here's where the
life insurance policy is here's where
the wheel is here's where these things
are so that anybody who titles cars it
has to come to real estate that's right
and who's going to come to my house and
go into my home because i'm no longer
alive and is going to have to figure out
what to do next and i got two little
kids with i wanted to be right there all
right and here's who to call here's the
right person here's the numbers to those
people and it i don't know it was the
one of the more peaceful exercises i've
been a part of
going through the numbers and the stuff
and the this and put it all together i
just felt at peace and i'll give props
to both sides of our family my parents
within this and winston's family has
done this where they did they listed out
everything and it's just like man the
intentionality is so great so that you
guys if you don't have life insurance
get term life if someone's dependent
upon your income i mean again these are
not fun conversations to have but think
about it plan about this is part of your
financial legacy so press into this
stuff and really leave
leave a great legacy to your family this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the housing market is hot and it has
been for a while so your house could be
worth a lot more today than it was when
you bought it and that means your old
insurance policy
might not give you enough coverage
anymore and what's the point of paying
for insurance that won't swing the cost
to repair or rebuild your home
oh that dude that would make me
insane oh if you lost your house in a
fire and you show up and like yep here's
your check and you're like
they only cover half the cost i'm like
well i don't know how to say this in
insurance terms but sucks to be you
sorry lumber's up
now some policies will automatically
raise your coverage to cover rising home
prices or material costs but not all of
them if your home's value has gone up or
it's been over a year since you checked
your homeowner's policy talk to one of
our endorsed local providers our elps
are independent independent agents who
will compare multiple policies to find
the best coverage visit
ramseysolutions.com
home
and find out why they're ramsay trusted
they put you first ramsey solutions.com
slash home
all right so rachel um during the break
james brought this in i think it's
right along what we were talking about
it's an article more than half of
americans feel embarrassed talking to
others about their finances so something
when i was doing i was counseling
clients in counseling practicum
dude within two or three sessions they
would talk about their sex lives they
would talk about things they like
because they didn't like intimate stuff
they would not talk about debt how much
debt do you have they just pick i'm not
ready like it was such a core thing and
it's been a long time wondering why and
the only thing i can come up with is
it's a it's a actual metric scorecard
yeah
you've said this before
it is like a yep
you can't hide you know me like you say
like i love english class because i can
just write a good essay and kind of tell
you what i feel about it math class was
hard dude because there's a right answer
and a wrong answer with debt like i know
there's a number here and um most are
not sure why money talk may be taboo
respondents say that most money
controversy the most controversial money
related topics are about their parents
finances
debt and wills debt 51 said parents
finances debt was 45 percent
43
debt in particular such a taboo topic
that nearly three and five people
distort their actual money situation
they lie about it on social media i love
this they distort it no they lie about a
lie they can't talk about here they're
financially stable 58 of people so i
will say this one of the things that
your parents gave you that my parents
gave we just talk about stuff we got you
got to talk about your will this show is
ruined because when someone asks a
question like well how much do you make
and how much debt do you have i'm
looking wrong
you just get so you you get it's not a
taboo yeah i'm like i don't know it's
not what i'm saying you're gonna die so
i'm numbers like let's just go yeah yeah
and are you gonna choose not to or are
you gonna choose two and have that
conversation but
wow wow wow
i mean it's tough okay so i thought this
was so funny
although three and four of the
respondents 76 say i'm an open book ask
me anything ask me anything
and in reality
63
say they actually have never discussed
money at the dinner table so so they're
waiting on everybody else to open the
book yes right i'm not i'm an open book
but no i'm not talking about this
and again there's a place a right and
wrong place to do this you know not at
the family dinner table by the way it's
never a good time to be like so let's go
around the table pass the rolls and uh
how much debt does everybody have what's
extended right then why right don't do
that but with your kids i'm like this
should be a dinner table topic why not
absolutely everything should be dinner
table topic with your kids i think that
is true speaking of that don't you have
cards that help with that i do except i
do we do have
sheila has said no not at the table no
no no not the cards all day long but
there's certain topics at the table she
said john not at the table and now my
kids i'll bring something up and they'll
be like not at the table dad
so you can guess it's usually body humor
but
um
but hey listen
let's just start norman this
talk to your parents about their
financial situation where they are how
they got to where they are start the
conversation like this hey i'm i'm in my
30s i'm in my 40s
i just need some wisdom will you walk me
through how and why you did what you did
when it came to money i'm just trying to
learn
everybody likes to be a good teacher
when you talk about hey this is how much
debt i have will you talk to me about
how much that you have so i was like
yeah like hey i've got this much debt i
don't know if this is good or if this is
bad can we talk about it hey do you have
a will like i want to honor you when
you're gone and we've never talked about
this and i know this is hard and i'm not
trying to whatever
can we talk about it right yeah and
parents please please give your kids the
gift of conversation and openness get a
will
right talk about your dad talk about
finances just be uh honest and open
that's right
all right up next we have micah
from memphis micah welcome to the show
hello can you guys hear me yeah you
better yeah how can we help all right
awesome i thought i wanted some advice
i'm um about ten thousand dollars upside
down on a car that's never got
and
i also have about 15
15 000 student loans okay
and
um in my current shop how much i'm
making now is about 30 000.
so the car is worth 30. you have 30 000
a year college worth about 32 and a
kelley blue book kelly blue book is uh
saying about 22 to 23. micah what kind
of car is it
it's a mustang
of course
i love that you laugh before you know
you know you got a car that is exactly
your annual salary what was in your head
man
i don't know i saw i walked in they just
gave me a call i was i was doing fine i
had a nice little corolla and one day i
got a call and they said hey come in you
might be able to get a nice trading
livestream
oh no yeah i mean they
oh man they got you hey here's the
here's the good news before rachel's
gonna walk you through it what will you
never do again
all right that's nothing close to this
there you go see hey how old are you
micah
i'm twenty-four yeah
i was doing stupid stuff like this into
my 30s so you what you won life you won
life man you made it you made it good
for you
oh my god that's so great well i'm glad
you called okay so
in this case i'd sell the car and you're
gonna have to just take out a loan for
the difference so instead of a 32 000
loan you're gonna have a ten thousand
dollar loan but no car so that means
you're gonna really have to
uh do you have any money saved anything
i'm broke i'm zero okay
so which so what i'm gonna what i you're
gonna have to do though is you're gonna
i mean you're probably you're gonna
need a car it's not gonna be a pretty
car it's not gonna be a mustang it's not
gonna be a 32 000 car uh you know we
call it a beater around here so i mean
this is a two thousand dollar i mean
you're gonna go back an older corolla
than the one you have yeah i mean it's
you're gonna go back a little bit but
that's okay only for a short period of
time micah only for a short period of
time right um replace that car and then
you're gonna start working on this debt
so you're going to have you know 25
grand um in debt and you're making 30.
so i i want you to what can i ask what
you do for a living
uh so that's the other thing so right
now i'm working just as security
but
lord willing in two weeks i start
another job
that's making another that's making
another 30 000. there you go 80 hours
i'll be at 80 hours per week and
seven days a week because i really i
just want to get get over with that's
what i'm talking about
for you get it man yes oh my god you're
gonna double
you're stuck your life's gonna look your
your life's gonna look different so soon
and i'm so excited for you so so yes i
would yes get rid of the car take out a
loan for the difference
and then you're gonna have 25 grand that
you'll be working out you're gonna pay
off that car loan first you're gonna
first get an emergency fund of a
thousand dollars then working to
pay off that 10 grand that 15. but
making 60 and are you are you single
micah
yes i don't think i don't know the whole
of my parents as well yeah that's great
well you know you're the expenses which
means are low so you're gonna be able
you're going to knock this what was your
total debt
25 000 15 15 student loan
15 student loan and then 10 if i if i
started selling this car okay so wait a
minute
there you go micah so 15 is 25
and you're still with your parents
on this day
in one calendar year you are debt-free
sitting in your new apartment that's you
got all on your own and you're gonna
call the show and you're gonna che we're
gonna cheer you on is that cool
you got one year of
hellacious grind ahead of you yep hang
on the line we're gonna send you um a
one-year subscription to ramsey plus to
jumpstart you because we believe in you
and we love you man so we're gonna send
you ramsey plus it's got all the fpu
videos it's got the every dollar app in
it it's got all the stuff that's gonna
launch you through this year to keep
grinding and grinding and grinding micah
you got this yes you're awesome man i
hear the resolve in his voice i'm pumped
for you pump for you micah thanks for
calling this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
the scripture of today is better as one
day in your courts than a thousand
elsewhere i would rather be a doorkeeper
in the house of my god than dwell in the
tents of the wicked psalm 84 10.
i don't know that there are any
shortcuts to doing a good job
sandra day o'connor
all right up next we have lexie in
dallas hey lexi welcome to the show
hey how are you doing great how can we
help
okay so i'm having a little debate with
my mom right now
my husband and i got married last year
and we didn't have a wedding and so next
year we're thinking about having a
destination wedding but we want to pay
for everybody to go
so
gen the destination like
like a movie theater
what's the destination can we are we
invited
lexi we'll come i'll come we'll come i'm
we're in to go to either distance or to
hawaii
whoa
well those are telling us you are way
way better friend than i am
way
way
how many people are having a couple
people
about 15 to 20 people
lexi i won't even send 15 to 20
postcards from my trip to hawaii
wow
john barely brings his children anywhere
okay so what's the debate about lexi
because hey you you got the money you
could have the money to do this we're
kind of just messing with you but what's
what's the debate what's the question
the debate is we are it will be about 30
to 40 000 to send everybody and i'm
trying to tell her like well people
spend 30 to 40 000 on a wedding for one
day all the time
so
that would be a seven-day trip
and so we just thought that it would be
better instead of spending that much on
one day
down here with all of our family we
would rather
take everybody have everybody that we
want there and then it's a whole
seven-day trip for everybody do you all
have the cash
so we will by that time would still pay
off debt we'll be done in probably about
a month but we make about 200
k a year okay i mean if you're debt-free
and you're
making that kind of money
i mean thirty thousand bucks isn't out
of balance for a wedding
i don't think is it rachel i mean no i
mean yeah i mean my rule of thumb always
is
if you have the money and it's not a
crazy amount of your net worth
um
that you're able to do it so yeah i mean
30 grand
uh it's not my i would i'm going to be
dr john deloney for a second i'm just
curious like see your um like your
motivation behind paying for everyone
because destination weddings are a thing
for sure but i think a lot of people
that are invited are expected
um to pay do you feel
for some reason like responsible do that
or is it just really just out of
generosity and you guys make a great you
guys are making 200 grand a year it's
awesome you just want to be generous
like i just i just want to hear more
about your motivation behind it
well yeah because when we were thinking
about having a wedding down here we
didn't think that it was fair for
everybody to have to pay you know for
their own food and our own dresses and
everything
and because we were like well if we want
people to be in the wedding then we need
to pay for them to be in the wedding so
i guess it's the same kind of motivation
by
bringing everybody down there like if we
want them to be there why make them pay
for such an expensive trip yeah well so
we in my wedding we
had a
i had a similar thought
and
but instead of buying everybody's
dresses my wife told everybody to buy
themself a new dress and everybody had
something different so that was just
kind of the way
it wasn't a themed thing right or i
got had all the guys wear outfits that
like they all had right and so there's
ways around it instead of buying
everything for everybody and i do think
i think there's a difference between hey
we're all getting together in dallas for
our wedding we want everybody here
and they opt in or opt out versus
an all expense paid trip to
to hawaii lexi how old are you
20 24 i'll be 25
okay yeah
i mean
it's your money i wouldn't but that's
your money
yeah i mean you you have the ability to
because you guys will be debt free right
will you have your emergency fund in
place by then as well
yes okay yeah i mean you're do i mean
i mean this is buying a
nice car you know on baby step four five
and six i mean it's the
i don't know john is cringing over there
it's making me nervous i mean i
it's i mean it's it's a and okay here's
gosh i don't know why i'm like splitting
hairs
because destin and hawaii are two very
different um price ranges yes so
um go to destin how about that then i'll
be happy
take everybody to destin for a week
you'll have fun and tell everybody y'all
have to pay for your own food i'm gonna
just say i'm gonna just caution you
alexi my caution is things are usually
more expensive
than you give them credit for
especially if you're taking two would
you say 20 people yeah there's no way
you do hawaii for twenty yeah for two
thousand dollars a person you won't be
able to fly them all there i don't think
even like the the airline tickets
themselves will be 500 right like yeah
not not you can't fly in hotels and
stuff hey do this for a week go to
ramseysolutions.com savings wedding
loans let's talk about our wedding loans
a good idea but also which you know
we're going to say no but in that
article it talks about
how to save for a wedding how to budget
for a wedding how to map all this stuff
out how to get on the same page because
you may be like yeah i think this is
right and your fiance may be like i
don't know about that so go to
ramseysolutions.com and just in the
search bar put how to plan for a wedding
or wedding loan's a good idea and
there's a whole article written on this
just just for this topic here yep yep so
so our answer is a little fuzzy for you
lexi it's like
you can you have money i know is it
necessary no
it's hawaii and destin are two very
different destinations you need to price
everything out and look at options all
of it but i would say at 24 because i
don't always hate when people like
discriminate on age oh yeah because it's
like i'm always the young one in life
and i was like oh my god you graduated
when
you're so little you know like i feel
like that's happened to me all the time
so i do not want to discriminate on your
age like i think you can be a bright 24
year old you're deaf free making 200 000
a year yeah i mean it's awesome it's
awesome but i do think too after
living life like
you know not that you would regret
up across these houses in these three
homes for the week um
you all are responsible for getting
yourself there or you're responsible for
your food when you're there or yeah let
some people have some skin in the game
yes that's fair that's fair we're going
to throw a big party and you'll you'll
cover the cost of the big houses or
something yeah yeah that's that feels
good john that was good we worked that
one out in real time we'll figure it out
so so good
um okay well john i'm excited for you in
your book the pre-sale everything going
on within your past
change your future okay so i want to
know from you before we end today's show
what's like the number one
thing you would tell people
to work on when it comes to their mental
health because i feel like anxiety is on
the rise depression like you hear all
this you hear all these stats and it's
just wild so if someone's listening
they're like i'm kind of not
uncomfortable with the conversation but
i don't even know where to start i don't
know what to do like what would be like
one thing that you would say to someone
okay here's a here's a great question to
ask yourself or here's
one thing to i don't know take an
inventory of your friends
take an inventory of your friends write
them down who would i call at 2am if my
wife was had to go to the er and had to
have somebody come over and be with the
kids who would i call
who have i hung out with regularly on a
weekly or bi-monthly basis for any
period of time more than just once more
than just twice
that i do life with here's the big one
who can i tell good stuff to
not just the negative stuff that you see
and you see some of the hallway like
how's it going well it's hot outside not
that person
if your kid got a part in a play what
friend would you call and yes i'm
talking to you truck driver get men
right who would you call and say hey
something good happened in my life hey
my wife just got her book published my
daughter just got straight a's in her
engineering class but who would you call
who would you call who would you tell
bad stuff to hey man i just got laid off
who would you pick up the phone and call
who would you drive over and see you'd
grab up three beers left and a casserole
take an inventory of your friends and
for most people in america it is
scary because we are a lonely lonely
crew then reach out and go hang out with
some people start over so good so good
you guys oh i love that's what i love
the show talk about money relationships
your life your health everything all of
it so on your past change your future
dave ramsey doctor ramsay solutions.com
pre-order today john so fun hosting with
you and thank you america
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you